can I just remind everyone to when
you're not speaking please just put your
mic on mute so we don't hear background
noises just for the benefit of everyone
else first item on the agenda is
apologies about absence and
substitutions Roberts over to you take
your chair we haven't received any but
obviously we as just mentioned Kasim
Matheson isn't here at the moment thank
you very much so everyone is present
apart from Casa Matheson okay second is
to receive any decorations for procuring
or non pecuniary interest by members
would anyone like to declare any
decorations yes yeah I am acquainted
with the owner of the listed building
Kyle's partl with Pikul which is
mentioned I was adjacent to the
meddlesome case planning application
number the DC 1905 105 nine one five the
landlord east of Chapel Road membership
that's the one yes thank you
anyone else have any decorations okay
thank you
move on to any decorations of lobbying
yes
who's saying yes I Sarah Mansell thank
you I I have been lobbied on the
Mendelson case DC in 1905 nine one five
okay thank you
anyone else can I change my declaration
on the county councillor for the
Fitzgerald Road area that gives me a
slightly more interest than other people
that's DC 1901 the 401 thank you okay
next item on the any decorations our
personal site visits by members
thank you okay so we're now going to
move to confirmation the minutes of the
meeting that was held on the 22nd of
January 2020 they're on page seven of
your papers through to page 16 starting
on if I just run through the pages seven
if you have anything just just just
holler
seven eight actually does anyone have
any point on any of the pages of those
minutes that I'd like to raise so is
everyone agreed that I can sign those is
a true record of the meeting if anyone
doesn't agree please speak oh as I'll
take it as read okay they approve thank
you very much next we move on to the
minutes of confirmation miss that was
held on the 19th of February 2020 which
one of them page 17 to page 30 of our
papers does anyone have any issues on
those minutes they wish to raise nope
okay so if no one speaks can I take it
therefore that we agree to confirm these
are accurate and they'll be signed
accordingly
no one's disagreeing with that so I'll
take that as read thank you very much we
now need to agenda item number 7 to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme Robert do we have any none
received you none received chair Robert
no is it thank you
okay next agenda item is agenda item
number eight schedule of planning
applications and can I ask John Pitman G
please to come in at this point
John can you come in please
John John can you hear me not quite sure
what's goofy huh Don two seconds I'll
try my count
hang on sorry I'm unfortunately my video
has busted on my laptop which means I
have to go through my phone I didn't
realize that my phone had locked out
because something has changed the
lockout apologized planning applications
please right ok start again
a cup for halfway through it so on the
5th May Miller's from parish council
took receipt of a new ESEA assessment
for the refreshed neighbourhood plan
which is part of the development plan of
the council as well the council saw the
committee for the neighbourhood plan has
met on this and make a recommendation
tonight to the parish council for this
to be published the assessment is
regarded as an evidence document for the
development plan so therefore it's
connected to our local plan as well
and it has been given significant
material weight obviously subject to
members judgement shrewd application on
the basis before put forward given the
sustainability of Ministers what are the
main issues of the assessment of the
application before members and given the
timing of this document being published
it is considered inappropriate to
consider the men - from cage today
without a full and detailed
understanding of this document to ensure
any decision reached can be robustly
defended as necessary furthermore we've
guard to both Brantford cases the road
and its duplicate given the very recent
refusal of sportin last week for 49
houses that was refused that is very
close to the Brantford sites it's
literally in sight of it
it may well be in the district of Weber
but officers do need to look at this
given the opinion
given by beba district council on
housing need landscape and heritage
matters to ensure consistent decision
making is made in this local area we are
also mindful of a recent appeal case law
Melford again I know that's Baber but
it's quite a significant case because
the inspector decided that development
should be approved regardless of the
five-year housing supply on recent
review the officer report in respect of
these very recent events it is
considered now that the report needs
further work and assessment to ensure
there was not a risk of jr. against any
decision regardless of which direction
that may take and we need to update the
report to reflect these matters on this
basis I would like to recommend that we
remove all three items from the agenda
and I note this is very unusual but it's
very unusual that we've had recent
changes to such an extent that we cannot
put a late paper in that we would
consider sufficient to cover these
issues in time thank you thank you
so I mean we don't vote on that I guess
it's do we need to vote on that in or
what is the process ah good morning
chairman I think no I well I think
essentially the off the office is
withdrawing the other items I mean we've
had to have the meeting because local
government under the provisions of local
government or mean you can't on summon
that's a very bad word for an English
graduate to user you can't cancel and
let's use the plain word a meeting
that's been summoned and I don't think I
both if mr. Carmichael agrees me we
don't need a formal vote to defer
because we simply note that the reports
are not presented so the reports are
withdrawn so there is no further
business what we're effectively saying
just to be clear on this yes chair and
it does in constant sorry in the
planning charter with you the provision
that has been referred to has been the
one that in consultation with the chair
yourself the reports have been withdrawn
by offices prior to the committee taking
place thank you for the update
clearly it's unfortunate we like to try
and keep to a tight timetable and we
were not in favor at all of applications
being withdrawn particularly at the last
minute because you know parishes and
residents all get ready to present their
cases and start thinking about how they
want to deal with that on the day so
it's regrettable but these things do
happen and we just have to accept that
on these occasions what's happened I
think it is right and proper that we
don't consider them today okay
so therefore members as there are no
planning applications on the on the
schedule to discuss the final item on
the agenda site inspections there are no
site inspections and therefore we'll be
closing the meeting at 9:41 and thank
you all for joining us
[Music]